because all of our entities are
simulated using physics bodies we lack
the ability to simply move our player to
our desired position
this type of teleportation can cause
issues with your physics environment
mainly teleported objects ignore physics
calculations until after their
teleportation has been resolved for
instance if we move the player to a
teleported position which is intersected
at the wall we could potentially get
stuck there and then confuse the physics
engine on what to do next since the
player is of course stuck as such rather
than teleporting the player we need to
update its velocity such that the
physics engine moves that unit to where
we want it to go next update loop now
all of our players actually have an MP
physics body variable this physics body
is given to us on the instantiation of
the player by allocating it from the
physics engine since we can't set the
physics body position directly due to
teleportation issues what we do instead
is a little bit of a workaround we take
advantage of the fact that the physics
engine is going to update all of the
physics bodies that it owns every frame
the physics bodies themselves allow you
to define a velocity vector on them when
the physics engine updates it adjusts
the position of the physics body by the
vector moving it correctly we in grits
can take advantage of this by supplying
a velocity vector that will move our
physics body to the position we want it
to be in avoiding the teleportation
issues